every prayer every fast every dot every
sucker every amaura every hatch every
act of worship for every act of worship
they do you get the same what am I
talking about you brothers and sisters
you get the same rewards for the people
who accept Islam from the Dower you
support the prophet salallahu alayhi wa
sallam said whoever calls others the
guidance will have a reward like the
reward of those who follow him without
that detracting from their reward in any
way for the price of less than a cup of
coffee a day he'll receive the same
rewards of people accepting Islam on
your scale of good deeds last year I era
had 5000 people accept Islam from all
over the globe this is your opportunity
to be part of that reward so what are
you waiting for you miss out now and
don't give during Ramadan you won't get
700 times more reward if an investment
was seven hundred times more you
wouldn't think twice imagine the reward
will Allah click the button and Don it
now
[Music]